Олексій Гончаренко європейська
Солідарність важливе рішення безумовно
треба підтримувати і ми на жаль маємо
приймати такі рішення тому що частина
території нашої держави до сих пір є
окупованою велика частина 20% території
кожна назва кожне село - це біль для
кожного українця але яким чином ми
будемо все це повертати це саме головне
сьогодні для нас питання ми приймаємо
технічні рішення як що робити в цій
ситуації але Перемога в руках одних
людей тих хто зранку до ночі сьогодні
воює за нашу державу тих хто В окопах
тих хто там по пояс в крові в багні
захищає нашу державу і я абсолютно
шокований результатами голосування яке
відбулося тільки що
99 голосів за ви вже всі голосували
тільки буквально три тижні тому за закон
повернення виплат нашим військовим
277 голосів за що трапилось куди ділося
178 голосів Що відбулося за ці три тижні
Невже офіс президента такий страшний
Невже так вам злячно прийняти рішення
щоб реально підтримати наших військових
не на словах на ділі давайте повертати
кажуть потрібні робочі групи будь ласка
давайте поки ми би сьогодні провалили цю
ганебну Постанову ганьба ці постанові
якою заблоковані виплати далі був би час
поки спікер підпише поки президент
підпише можна було будь-яку робочу групу
зібрати будь-що вирішити Якщо є бажання
А якщо бажання нема продовжується
знущання з наших героїв тих хто має має
звільнити нашу землю і перемогти це
реальна ганьба і кожне ім'я буде відомо
і ви зробили Не просто помилку а злочин